do you think we will one day spend most
or all of our lives in uh virtual
reality worlds
i have always found the very most
valuable moment in virtual virtuality to
be the moment when you take off the
headset and your senses are refreshed
and you perceive physicality
uh afresh you know as if you were a
newborn baby but
with a little more experience so you can
really notice just how incredibly
strange and
delicate and peculiar and impossible the
real world is
um
so the magic
is and perhaps forever will be in the
physical world
well that's my take on it that's just me
i mean i think i don't get to tell
everybody else how to think or how to
experience virtual reality and at this
point there have been
multiple generations of younger people
who've
come along and liberated me from having
to worry about these things
uh but i should say also even in uh what
some well i called it mixed reality back
in the day and these days it's called
augmented reality uh but with something
like a hololens even then
like one of my favorite things is to
augment a forest not because i think the
forest needs augmentation but when you
look at
the augmentation next to a real tree the
real tree just pops out as being
astounding you know it's
it's
interactive it's changing slightly all
the time if you pay attention and it's
hard to pay attention to that but when
you compare to virtual reality all of a
sudden you do
and even in practical applications my
favorite
early application of virtuality which we
prototyped going back to the 80s when i
was working with dr joe rosen at
stanford med near near where we are now
we made the first surgical simulator and
to go from
the fake anatomy of the simulation which
is incredibly valuable for many things
for designing procedures for training
for all kinds of things then to go to
the real person
boy it's really something like uh
surgeons really get woken up by that
transition it's very cool so i think the
transition is actually more valuable
than the simulation
that's fascinating i never
really thought about that it's almost
it's like traveling elsewhere in the
physical space
can help you appreciate how much you
value your home once you return
well that's how i take it i mean
once again people have different
attitudes towards it all are welcome
what do you think is the difference
between the virtual world and the
physical meet space world that that you
are still drawn for you personally still
drawn to the physical world
like there clearly then is a distinction
is there some fundamental distinction or
is it the peculiarities of the current
set of technology
in terms of the kind of virtuality that
we have now
uh it's made of software and software is
terrible stuff yeah software
is always the slave of its own history
its own legacy
it's always um
infinitely arbitrarily messy and
arbitrary working with it brings out a
certain kind of nerdy personality in
people or at least in me
which um i'm not that fond of and there
are all kinds of things about software i
don't like
and so that's different from the
physical world
it's not something we understand as you
just pointed out on the other hand you
know i'm a little mystified when people
ask me well do you think the universe is
a computer
and i have to say well i mean
what on earth could you possibly mean if
you say it isn't a computer if it isn't
a computer
it
wouldn't
follow principles consistently and it
wouldn't be intelligible because what
else is a computer ultimately you know i
mean and we have physics we have
technology you know so we can do
technology so we can program it so i
mean of course it's some kind of
computer but
i think trying to understand it as a
turing machine is probably
a foolish approach
right that's the question whether
it performs this computer we call the
universe performs the kind of
computation that can be modeled as a
universal touring machine or is it
something much more fancy
so fancy in fact that we it may be
beyond our cognitive capabilities to
understand
turing machines are kind of
um
i'd call them teases in a way
because like
if you have
an infinitely smart programmer with an
infinite amount of time an infinite
amount of memory and an infinite clock
speed
then they're universal but yeah that
cannot exist so they're not universal in
practice and they they actually are
in practice a very particular sort of
machine within
you know the constraints within
the conservation principles of any
reality that's
worth being in probably and so
so i i
uh
i think
the universality of a particular model
is probably a deceptive way to think
even though it's some sort of limit of
course it's can it
something like that's got to be true at
some sort of
high enough limit but it's just not
accessible to us so what's the point
you